sources are one of the important ways
shifts add extra dimension and flavor to
dishes you can use this trick at home my
camera is cranberry and apple sauce is
another recipe I always cook a day in
advance it packs a wonderful punch that
really lives the subtle flavor of the
turkey
it's simple to make and with its deep
red vibrant color looks fantastic on the
plate the secret behind any good
Christmas is in the organization and
preparation anything you can get done in
advance do it apple and cranberry sauce
is a prime example first things first
we're gonna make a really nice caramel
sugar in at 150 grams of caster sugar to
a pan followed by a couple of star anis
that helps to really give a nice sort of
aniseed flavor to the cranberries next
lightly crushed four cardamom pods this
has a lovely warm spicy sweet flavour
and wait for the sugar to melt and form
a caramel really important out the
confidence now to color that caramel
still gets really nice and dark before
put the cranberries
[Music]
Wow smell of that camera is amazing
no cranberries in
members are very tart and acidic but
balanced with the sweetness of the
caramel and apples they give the sauce a
lovely dry sharp note to tell if it's
fresh
drop them on a hard service the higher
they bounce the fresher they are the
secret now is sort of caramel to blister
the cranberries and really start to
break that down smells fantastic next
core peel and thinly sliced two apples
unless the sauce is finished it really
just helps to sort of wake up the flavor
of the turkey now the cranberries are
starting to break down Apple in smells
fantastic a touch of salt and pepper
that's really important really helps to
balance that tartness against the
acidity of the Apple Psalm pepper really
brings it back the smell is fantastic so
I sort of sweet sour spicy nice now from
there
deglaze the pan with touch a port round
the side the glazing dissolves all the
lovely sticky Kami's bits of food that
are stuck to the pan and incorporates
them into the sauce
next add the zest of an orange and for
another layer of fragrant sweetness
squeezing the juice then cook on a low
heat for five to ten minutes to thicken
but remember the source will become even
thicker once it's cooled down now that
is the right texture I don't want a
runny sauce I want something really nice
and thick delicious packed full of
flavor perfect if you really want to get
ahead this sauce can be made three or
four days in advance and kept in the
fridge which allows the flavors to
develop even more
[Music]
then on Christmas Day
simply bring it up to room temperature
and serve another job done leaving you
more time to enjoy this very special day
[Music]